[Music]  okay  [Music]  myself  come over let's do this over come beat  my shoulder to cry on  life really ain't been the same since  you've been gone cause you're addictive  side effects include missing you  loss of appetite sleepless nights and  trust  issues  [Music]  you should have come  [Music]  you're in bed with someone else a saying  you miss me  and i'm crying on the bathroom floor  wishing i didn't leave  this love is expired but i still  desire your refill  [Music]  a refill  cause you're addictive  [Music]  is  [Music]  this feeling is fatal mentally unstable  you should have come  with a warning  [Music]  you should have come  with a warning  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you should  label  [Music]